apple's 13-inch macbook pro has just
been released for 2020
and since a lot of people have been
waiting to upgrade i'm gonna walk you
through some mistakes you should avoid
when buying a new macbook and then i'll
finish off with which model you should
buy
for your specific use case as well as
which upgrades are worth it and which
ones aren't
we already made a video answering your
guys's questions about
why apple kept the 8th gen chip in the
base model
and when we expect the 14 inch macbook
pro redesign to get
released so if any of that sounds
interesting to you
make sure to click the end screen button
at the end of this video to check it out
this year there are only a couple of
changes on the base model
the switch to the excellent new magic
keyboard that comes with a physical
escape key
and getting double the storage for the
same price now if you're wanting to make
this
upgrade solely because of that magic
keyboard then you need to be sure to
avoid mistake number one
not everyone knows that the 2020 macbook
air also gets the exact same
new magic keyboard while also getting
better battery life
and it's 300 cheaper as well so if you
just want that great new keyboard and
you don't really care that much about
performance
then the macbook air is actually a much
better buy for you
but be sure to keep in mind that the
quad core model of the macbook air
suffers from some
overheating issues so you should check
out our overheating video
after this now for those who do care
about performance
or those who want a better display with
higher color accuracy
the new 13-inch macbook pro is for you
there are two models
the base 1300 model which didn't change
very much
and then the 1800 model which comes with
a new
10th gen cpu which packs faster
processor and graphics performance
it comes with more ram that's even
faster than before
more storage and other features that
i'll mention in just a minute
moving on to mistake number two if
you're going to be buying the base model
then absolutely do not pay for the 300
processor upgrade because first of all
it won't make that big of a difference
in performance
and second of all you're now only two
hundred dollars away
from the more expensive eighteen hundred
dollar model
which has an i5 processor that will blow
this i7 cpu away
in terms of performance for mistake
number three if you wanna buy the base
model but also
upgrade to 16 gigs of ram and 512 gigs
of storage
you might not realize that the 1800
model already has these specs
but it also comes with a much better 10
chen processor
and a bunch of other features like much
faster graphics performance
much faster ram speed and extra two
thunderbolt 3 ports
two cooling fans instead of just one
upgraded speaker quality
and support for connecting a 6k
resolution display
now on the flip side i do actually think
it makes sense to upgrade just the ram
to 16 gigs
if you like to do a lot of multitasking
like with lots of chrome tabs
for a total of 1400 dollars so mistake
number four
is not upgrading the ram when you really
should but of course
this depends on your use case on to
mistake number five
don't go overboard and spend eight
hundred dollars on two terabytes of ssd
storage
i personally think that most consumers
should be fine with one terabyte
so you should put that extra money into
upgrades that you'll notice every day
like buying the 1800 model now the rest
of these mistakes have to do with that
more expensive macbook pro
mistake number six would be spending 200
upgrading the cpu
to the i7 there realistically isn't any
difference between the i5 and the i7
except for clock speeds and from past
experience
there really isn't a big noticeable
difference when you spend that cash
so that 200 will be much better spent on
getting one terabyte of storage
or going towards the ram upgrade however
make sure to also avoid mistake number
seven
don't upgrade to 32 gigs of ram unless
you absolutely know you need it
because it'll only make a difference if
the tasks you work on
are actually able to max out 16 gigs of
ram now on to mistake number eight
you might be tempted to choose the 1800
model and upgrade everything to get a
crazy fast machine
but you might not know that the 16-inch
macbook pro has certain
advantages that make it a much better
choice for some people
like the fact that it gets a 6 core
processor at the base price
a dedicated graphics card that gives you
a huge boost in graphics performance
and other features like better speakers
and microphones
and finally for mistake number nine you
might be holding off on upgrading
because you're waiting for the upcoming
14 inch macbook pro redesign which is
coming either at the end of this year
or early next year but i'm fairly
certain that
only the higher end 1800 model will be
upgraded to that 14 inch design or at
least
at first so if you realistically can't
see yourself spending at least eighteen
hundred dollars
on that new macbook pro then it would
actually be a mistake
waiting for that instead of buying the
thirteen 1300 model right
now and enjoying it for the extra months
that you would have waited so now that
we have those mistakes out of the way
let's get right into the buyer's guide
first off if you do a little bit of
photo editing
programming video editing or using logic
pro 10
every once in a while then the base 1300
macbook pro is an
excellent choice since it comes with the
color accurate and bright display
along with the well-cooled quad-core
processor now if you do productivity
work like that very often
then i would recommend upgrading to 16
gigs of ram
because we found that it greatly helps
with things like video and photo editing
but you should also be careful to not
upgrade too many things
i'd say that a good rule of thumb is if
your thirteen hundred dollar model
ends up being sixteen hundred dollars
when you're finished adding upgrades
then i would honestly recommend just
spending two hundred dollars more
on the 1800 model since it already comes
with 16 gigs of ram
512 gigs of storage and other great
features like better speakers and extra
two ports
and an extra cooling fan now for those
who really take their work
seriously or for those who are going to
be using the macbook pro to make money
then i would definitely recommend that
you buy the 1800
model because of the faster 10th gen
processor
faster 3733 megahertz ram
extra ports and better cooling system
and on top of that
the base 512 gig ssd should be faster
than the 256 gig one
in the 1300 model now if you're a
dedicated photo editor
i think that for the first time ever
this 13 inch macbook pro
is actually suitable for heavy photo
editing
since the new 10-gen chip is very
efficient and it now comes with a 32 gig
ram option last year we recommended the
16-inch macbook pro for very serious
photo editors
because of the 32 gig ram option because
it's by far
the biggest thing that affects photo
editing even more so than the 6 core
processor
and 32 gigs is really the sweet spot so
now you can get the 13 inch macbook pro
with 32 gigs of ram for 2200
instead of 2 800 for 32 gigs on this 16
inch macbook pro
so that's a really great savings this
would also be a really great choice for
anyone who does programming or any other
tasks that they know
can use that much ram and in terms of
storage options
i would recommend getting one terabyte
of ssd storage for serious productivity
work now video editing does benefit for
more ram
but we would honestly recommend anyone
that's doing serious video editing
or graphics processing work to just go
for the 16-inch macbook pro
because it gets a dedicated graphics
chip and this will make the biggest
difference by far
even with the new integrated graphics
and the 13-inch macbook pro
it still gets nowhere near as much
graphics performance
compared to the base 16-inch pro so keep
that in mind
and finally if you don't really care
about specs and performance
and the overall macbook experience means
more to you
then i would honestly recommend holding
off for the 14 inch macbook pro redesign
which could be coming either later this
year or early next year
so if this video helped you make a
decision on which macbook pro you should
buy
we'll have links to the best deals down
in the description below
and if you're still confused on which
one to buy then you can leave a comment
down below
and we'll help you out with your
specific use case now we've already
ordered these new 2020 macbook pros so
if you don't want to miss out on our
in-depth comparison videos
you can click that circle above to
subscribe right now and click that bell
below so you don't miss out on the
notifications
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video